c'est non non uniquement planter ou de
la ddh poussé par les embruns labeyrie
goulaine pas barigoule and tan
folichonne labeyrie goulaine viêt lutter
jour le retour du marin parti naguère
guerroyer le hareng à bord du trois-mâts
le remous mais leur moutarde et la burie
goulaine s'étiole je m'étiole le jour ça
va encore je compte les mouettes
mais à partir de 20h30 je peux dire que
je m'étiole berry goulaine bérigaud l'un
ne vous étiez les plus la minute
nécessaire de monsieur cyclopède va
revenir tous les soirs à 20h30 sur une
chaîne de télévision dont je tairai le
nom pour ne pas faire de publicité à fr3
maintenant que monsieur cyclopède est de
retour je peux dire que je me fends la
coiffe étonnant nous
[Musique]
etonnant non